Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: 卧槽这个他妈的
Shure: Damn, this is f***ing...
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: 跨肩膀肩膀跨
Shure: Cross shoulders, shoulders cross.
Shure: 这几个关节好像2哒3哒45678 哇
Shure: These joints are like 2 da 3 da 4 5 6 7 8. Wow.
Lucia: 军体拳预备
Lucia: Hip punch ready.
Shure: 还扎马步
Shure: And horse stance.
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Shure: 张元英转圈是吧
Shure: Zhang Yuyan spinning, right?
Shure: 不行这真不会啊
Shure: No, I really can't do this.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 这是0.5倍速是吗
Shure: Is this 0.5x speed?
Lucia: 哎等等我脚错了
Lucia: 卡了吧
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Shure: one two three four
Shure: One two three four
Shure: one two three four 1234what fuck 23 哇吼
Shure: One two three four 1 2 3 4. Wow, f*** 2 3. Wow.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Lucia: 哎好快这一边
Lucia: Hey, this side is so fast.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 不行了不行了
Shure: I can't, I can't do it anymore.
Katrina: 先把前两部分
Katrina: Let's do the first two parts.
Alice:哦哈哈
Alice: Oh haha.
Jake:再来一次
Jake: One more time.
Shure: ok
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 把前两部分回顾一下
Katrina: Let's review the first two parts.
其他人：我们就靠前两个
Choiszt: We'll just rely on the first two.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 脑容量要炸了
Shure: My brain is about to explode.
Katrina: 手机呢调往前调一下
Katrina: Where's the phone? Adjust it forward a bit.
Jake:放哪了
Jake: Where did you put it?
Katrina: 你是要录我们刚刚跟音乐的吗
Katrina: Are you recording us with the music just now?
Katrina: 还是从头
Katrina: Or from the beginning?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:就是你们来跳一次比较完整的就行
Jake: Just dance through it once completely, that's fine.
Shure: 那我们给大家展示一下这个第一部分
Shure: Let's show everyone the first part.
Shure: 我们跳的最好的这一部分吧
Shure: The part we dance best.
Jake:全景相机
Jake: Panoramic camera.
Jake:就是相当于这边处一人看你们
Jake: It's like someone here is watching you.
Shure: OK准备好了吗ready
Shure: OK, are you ready? Ready?
Shure: 二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 三二三四五六七八
Shure: Three, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 四二三四跑二三起
Shure: Four, two, three, four, run, two, three, lift.
Shure: 一二三四张二收
Shure: One, two, three, four, stretch, two, close.
Shure: 二三二三四把来二三滑
Shure: Two, three, two, three, four, hold, two, three, slide.
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 伸二比心张
Shure: Stretch, two, heart shape, open.
Shure: 二三走一二
Shure: Two, three, go, one, two.
Shure: 二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 一二三四五六七八
Shure: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 踏步二一二三四
Shure: Step, two, one, two, three, four.
Shure: 一二三四跑
Shure: One, two, three, four, run.
Shure: 跳二三四
Shure: Jump, two, three, four.
Shure: 张二收二三四划二三四
Shure: Stretch, two, close, two, three, four, slide, two, three, four.
Shure: 摸手二三四顶二三四
Shure: Touch hand, two, three, four, push, two, three, four.
Shure: 二三四一二三停
Shure: Two, three, four, one, two, three, stop.
Lucia: 哎又卡帧了
Lucia: Ugh, the frame's frozen again.
Shure: 简单
Shure: Simple.
Katrina: 第二部分要不要再过一遍
Katrina: Should we go over the second part again?
Shure: 来第二部分
Shure: Let's do the second part.
Shure: 再跟他过一遍
Shure: Let's go over it again.
其他人：直接0.75
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Katrina: 哇你就这么自信的吗
Katrina: Wow, you're that confident?
Jake:这是OK
Jake: This is OK.
Lucia: 这三部分加起来
Lucia: Adding these three parts up,
Lucia: 好像没有到完整的时长
Lucia: It doesn't seem to be the full length.
Lucia: 那就从头单曲循环
Lucia: Then let's loop it from the start.
Shure: 一二三四二二三四一二甩
Shure: One two three four two two three four one two swing
Shure: 二张二开二一二三四
Shure: Two, open two, one two three four
Lucia: 哈哈等一下太快了
Lucia: Haha, wait a minute, that's too fast
Shure: 41234223412
Shure: 对go一二三四五六七八
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two two three four five six seven eight
Shure: 转胯三四五六拍拍
Shure: Hip twist three four five six clap clap
Shure: 一二三四五六七停
Shure: One two three four five six seven stop
Lucia: 哈哈我觉得第二趴还是练一下吧
Lucia: Haha, I think we should practice the second part again
Lucia: 因为手和脚上动作要合一下
Lucia: Because we need to sync the hand and foot movements
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Jake:好好下一个环节
Jake: Alright, next segment
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Katrina: 啊下一个环节
Katrina: Ah, next segment
Jake:你的花
Katrina: 哦哦哦你说行
Katrina: Oh oh oh, you mean okay
其他人：跳舞结束了是吧
Jake:行吧好好好行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay
Shure: 呀呀呀呀呀呀呀
Shure: Ya ya ya ya ya ya ya
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake:都录着了
Jake: It's all recorded
Jake:啊哈哈好
Jake: Ah haha, good
Katrina: 行吧去选花吧
Katrina: Alright, let's go choose flowers
Shure: 他的出镜率不比他来的出镜率低是吧
Shure: His screen time isn't less than when he came, right?
Jake:对我们第第7位选手
Jake: Yes, our seventh contestant
Katrina: 几点钟了
Katrina: What time is it?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 哦 4点了
Katrina: Oh, it's 4 o'clock
Katrina: 是不是也得准备菜啥的啊
Katrina: Should we also start preparing the dishes?
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right
Katrina: 那就选一下花
Katrina: Then let's choose the flowers
Jake:对拧个花就是我们的活动
Jake: Yes, picking flowers is part of our activity
Jake:我们可以再给你跟跟剧组讲解一下的
Jake: We can also explain to you and the crew
Jake:一些
Jake: Some things
Nicous: 插花还是做的干花
Nicous: Are we arranging flowers or making dried ones?
Jake:也不是就是可能是7天
Jake: Neither, it's probably just seven days
Jake:呃看着一一束花就长开
Jake: Uh, just watching a bunch of flowers bloom
Tasha: 没学会
Tasha: Haven't learned
Jake:走吧下去吧
Jake: Let's go downstairs
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 反正真的记住他要记挺长一阵子
Lucia: Anyway, if you really remember him, it'll be for a long time.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:得一直处于摄像头上
Jake: He needs to always be on camera.
Jake:那不行没有的话
Jake: Otherwise, it won't work.
Lucia: 但是理论上说
Lucia: But theoretically,
Lucia: 最后跳怎样其实不是特别重要
Lucia: how he jumps in the end isn't that important.
Lucia: 对吧我们只要有这个数据就行哈
Lucia: Right? As long as we have the data, it's fine.
Katrina: 写一下名字簿
Katrina: Write the name in the book.
Katrina: 然后贴挑一束花
Katrina: Then pick a bunch of flowers.
Katrina: 然后每天要给他拍照
Katrina: And take a photo of it every day.
其他人：这么牛逼啊
Katrina: 对因为有了花苞
Katrina: Yes, because it has buds now.
Katrina: 这就是他会慢慢盛开
Katrina: So, it will slowly bloom.
Katrina: 写名字写名字贴
Katrina: Write the name, write the name, and stick it.
Shure: 写名字
Shure: Write the name.
Jake:写名字写呗
Jake: Write the name, go ahead.
Katrina: 那这我挑了
Katrina: Okay, I'll pick this one.
Choiszt: 也是好
Choiszt: That's good too.
Shure: 谁让你挑的呵呵呵
Katrina: 偷偷挑的
Katrina: I picked it secretly.
Katrina: 挑是最好的
Katrina: It's the best choice.
Alice: 这么就是
Alice: So, it's like this.
其他人：待会我两吃啥
Choiszt: What are we eating later?
Katrina: 今晚上还可以再练
Katrina: We can practice again tonight.
Jake:哎你你俩有
Jake: Hey, do you two have...
Lucia: 咦sorry
Lucia: One less, right.
Jake:有你俩事
Jake: Do you two have something going on?
Jake:你俩在打
Jake: Are you two arguing?
Jake:我出去来
Jake: I'm stepping out for a bit.
Choiszt: ok
Choiszt: OK.
Nicous: ok
Nicous: OK.
Katrina: 我的草莓种
Katrina: My strawberries are planted.
Jake:到位了啊兄弟们到位了
Jake: Alright, guys, we're all set.
Tasha: 嗯哦
Tasha: Hmm, oh.
Tasha: 这有人了
Tasha: There's someone here.
Tasha: 名花有主了
Tasha: The spot is taken.
Lucia: 啊内个也有
Lucia: Ah, there's another one too.
Tasha: 那就你吧
Tasha: Then it's you.
Lucia: 那我就这个好了反正他离我最近的
Lucia: Then I'll take this one since it's the closest to me.
Katrina: 这是要泡几分钟
Katrina: How many minutes should this soak?
Alice:这个好像没有勺药
Alice: It looks like there's no peony here.
Lucia: 有他应该是还没开
Lucia: There is, it just hasn't bloomed yet.
Lucia: 就是应该各种就里面都都放了
Lucia: It should be placed all around inside.
Alice:应该只有一个
Alice: There should only be one.
Katrina: 都都放了芍药的球球
Katrina: They're all peony bulbs.
Katrina: 等它慢慢开就行
Katrina: Just wait for them to bloom slowly.
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Katrina: 对这些都是芍药球
Katrina: Yes, these are all peony bulbs.
Alice:找个多一点的
Alice: Find one with more.
Shure: 哎我去刚刚一直
Shure: Oh man, I was just...
Katrina: 芍药开出
Katrina: The peony blooms...
Lucia: 啊我可以写了哎
Lucia: Ah, I can write it now.
Katrina: 来好大呀
Katrina: Wow, it's so big.
Lucia: 笔上哪去了在这
Lucia: Where did the pen go? Here it is.
Katrina: 出来出来出来
Katrina: Come out, come out.
Katrina: 自己房间装饰
Katrina: Decorate your own room.
Shure: 我房间已经靠了
Shure: My room is already decorated.
其他人：来来来我过一下过一下
Choiszt: Let me pass through.
Shure: 我感觉我
Shure: I feel like...
Lucia: 可以把它融入到我们的房间装饰里
Lucia: You can incorporate it into our room decor.
Katrina: 你也可以把它放在这客厅某一个位置
Katrina: You can also place it in a corner of the living room.
Katrina: 都行反正你自己管着
Katrina: Whatever, it's up to you.
Katrina: 他每天要拍照
Katrina: He needs to take photos of it every day.
Shure: 每天要拍照
Shure: Take photos every day.
Katrina: 哎呀老学我的口音干什么
Katrina: Oh, stop mimicking my accent.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈可以放外面播
Katrina: Hahaha, you can broadcast it outside.
Katrina: 他需要那个光合作用吗
Katrina: It needs photosynthesis, right?
Shure: 外面不好吧
Shure: Outside isn't good.
Katrina: 就是生物钟
Katrina: It's a biological clock.
Katrina: 他们是需要进行光合作用好像
Katrina: They need to do photosynthesis, I think.
Katrina: 但是也不能长时间进行光合作用
Katrina: But they can't do it for too long.
Katrina: 你还记得吗
Katrina: Do you remember?
Choiszt: 这个灯其实也可以给他做
Choiszt: This lamp can actually work for it.
Katrina: 好像会那个什么死掉
Katrina: It might die though.
Katrina: 就是那个气口
Katrina: Because of the stomata.
Shure: 蒸腾作用过的
Shure: Due to transpiration.
Katrina: 对对真疼
Katrina: Yeah, transpiration.
Lucia: 灯也是可以的吗
Lucia: Can the lamp work too?
Shure: 你看看这脑子
Shure: Look at this brain.
Katrina: 就是有文化
Katrina: That's what you call cultured.
Tasha: 嗯这怎么断了一根
Tasha: Hmm, why is one branch broken?
Choiszt: 闹谁了
Choiszt: Who did that?
Alice: 断了一根
Alice: One branch is broken.
Choiszt: 帮我拿一个饮料
Choiszt: Get me a drink.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Tasha:在楼上
Tasha: It's upstairs.
Shure: Dyson i need a corporation
Shure: Dyson, I need a corporation.
Jake:哪去了
Jake: Where did it go?
Shure: 这个放哪呢
Shure: Where should I put this?
Shure: 我那面是阴面不宜养花
Shure: My side is shady, not suitable for growing flowers.
Lucia: 一股辟谷
Lucia: Smells like fasting.
Alice: 两个
Alice: Two.
Lucia: 放哪呢
Lucia: Where should I put this?
Lucia: 我觉得我房间要放阳台上
Lucia: I think I should put it on the balcony in my room.
Lucia: 挺容易掉下来的
Lucia: It's pretty easy to fall off.
Lucia: 因为我那阳台它并不大
Lucia: Because my balcony isn't that big.
Choiszt: 橙汁没了
Choiszt: We ran out of orange juice.
Nicous: 我槽
Nicous: Oh crap.
Choiszt: 这行大一点
Choiszt: This one should be bigger.
Nicous: 明白
Nicous: Got it.
Choiszt: 大了
Choiszt: It's bigger.
Nicous: 这这这我错的了
Nicous: This, this, this is my fault.
Jake:呃等下找不着了
Jake: Uh, wait, can't find it now.
Lucia: 快快快
Lucia: Quick, quick, quick!
Choiszt: 我擦
Choiszt: Damn it!
Nicous: 插哪里
Nicous: Where to plug it in?
Jake:敲完了吗大伙
Jake: Is everyone done knocking?
Lucia: 哎呦sorry
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Lucia: 这么会
Lucia: How come?
Alice:你贴了吗
Alice: Did you stick it?
Jake:对啊我也觉得
Jake: Yeah, I think so too.
Jake:你拿下来了
Jake: You took it down.
Katrina:  这个是你的吗
Katrina: Is this yours?
Jake:那你放哪去
Jake: So where did you put it?
Tasha: 最里面那个
Tasha: The one at the very back.
Katrina:  今天拍啥
Katrina: What are we shooting today?
Lucia: 今天的照片我把它放哪拍呢
Lucia: Where should I take today's photo?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 看看芍药需要几天才能开花
Katrina: Let's see how many days it takes for the peonies to bloom.
Lucia: 昂
Lucia: Hmm
Lucia: 这里
Lucia: Here
Lucia: 昂
Lucia: Hmm
Jake:幸亏他妈的奶可乐
Jake: Luckily, there’s milk cola.
Lucia: 有一点点背光其实
Lucia: There's a little bit of backlight actually.
Jake:哎呀挑好了吗
Jake: Hey, is it adjusted?
Alice:这个是可以剪花的
Alice: This one can be trimmed.
Jake:给我留的哪个呀
Jake: Which one is reserved for me?
Tasha: 那要不拿昨天那个剪
Tasha: How about using the one from yesterday?
Katrina: 是不是最里面那个这个这
Katrina: Is it the one inside? This one?
Alice:昨天那个在哪
Alice: Where's the one from yesterday?
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Jake:这什么花呀
Jake: What flower is this?
Katrina: 这是芍药
Katrina: This is a peony.
Katrina: 这应该也是芍药
Katrina: This one should be a peony too.
Katrina: 这是康乃馨
Katrina: This is a carnation.
Katrina: 然后这是百合
Katrina: And this is a lily.
Alice:哎剪子在哪里
Alice: Hey, where are the scissors?
Katrina: 就买了这几种
Katrina: I only bought these kinds.
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: They are over here.
Alice:剪花的那个
Alice: The flower scissors.
Shure: 我给自己的花起个名吧
Shure: I should name my flower.
Katrina: sunshine好土
Katrina: "Sunshine" is so tacky.
Katrina: 你可以叫sunshine或者叫smile
Katrina: You could call it "Sunshine" or "Smile".
Shure: smart可还行
Shure: How about "Smart"?
Katrina: 微笑
Katrina: Smile.
Lucia: 好看
Lucia: Looks good.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:这个不能乱关
Jake: This can't be turned off randomly.
Jake:所以关了硬盘就会好
Jake: So if it’s off, the hard drive will be fine.
Jake:然后搞成这个样子
Jake: And then it ended up like this.
Jake:血汗工厂开店
Jake: Sweatshop opening.
Choiszt: 刚才做这儿
Choiszt: Just doing this here.
Jake:thrill
Jake: Thrill.
Choiszt: 我擦
Choiszt: Damn.
Choiszt: 这个只能别这
Choiszt: This can only be here.
Nicous: 可能就这样
Nicous: Maybe it’s just like this.
Jake:你你们进去吧
Jake: You guys go in.
Jake:这这两个给你们
Jake: Here, these two are for you.
Katrina: 哇好像那是自习室啊
Katrina: Wow, it looks like a study room.
Jake:这
Jake: This...
Katrina: 就是那补习班
Katrina: It's like a tutoring center.
Jake:哎呦让我出去
Jake: Oh, let me out.
Katrina: 然后现在推门进去减负
Katrina: And now, push the door open to reduce the workload.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, right.
Jake:血汗工厂
Jake: Sweatshop.
Katrina: 不准办补习班
Katrina: No tutoring centers allowed.
Choiszt: 不准办公
Choiszt: No offices allowed.
Jake:不准办公
Jake: No offices allowed.
Lucia: 不可办公
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈太搞笑了
Katrina: Hahaha, that's so funny.
Jake:不准办公
Jake: No offices allowed.
Lucia: 不准办公
Lucia: No offices allowed.
Jake:禁止办公
Jake: No offices allowed.
Jake:这边贴一个禁止办公
Jake: Let's stick a "No offices allowed" sign here.
Lucia: 这标这标语我喜欢
Lucia: I like this slogan.
Katrina: 哈哈哈拍拍坐像那种
Katrina: Hahaha, take a photo like that.
Shure: 你们你们仨是网吧
Shure: You guys are like an internet cafe.
Shure: 3连坐是吗
Shure: Three in a row, right?
Katrina: 哈哈哈真的像
Katrina: Hahaha, it really looks like it.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这外面这桌子是不是有点有点歪
Lucia: Isn't this table a bit crooked outside?
Lucia: 这个板
Lucia: This board...
Choiszt: 你为啥不收会计
Choiszt: Why don't you collect the accounting?
Lucia: 不是就是这板好像不太平
Lucia: No, this board doesn't seem very flat.
Jake:对对对是的是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it isn't.
Lucia: 对对对是平时不够哦OK
Lucia: Yeah, it's usually not enough, oh OK.
Jake:他就是不够
Jake: It really isn't enough.
Jake:哈哈哈很勉强
Jake: Hahaha, it's barely acceptable.
Jake:不过也行这样就好
Jake: But it's fine, this will do.
Choiszt: 我超这个题题
Choiszt: I super this question.
Shure: 你们仨准备打点什么
Shure: What are you guys planning to play?
Shure: 英雄联盟吗
Shure: League of Legends?
Jake:三个人能打什么呀
Jake: What can three people play?
Jake:帮我拿一下
Jake: Help me hold this.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
其他人：斗斗地主
Choiszt: Let's play Dou Dizhu.
Lucia: 三个人
Lucia: Three people.
Jake:帮我拿一下
Jake: Help me grab this.
Shure: 三个人APEX
Shure: Three people in Apex.
Lucia: 三个人可以
Lucia: Three people can do it.
Lucia: 三个人可以联机玩刺客信条黑棋可以6
Lucia: Three people can play Assassin's Creed Black Flag online, cool.
Shure: 可以永结无间
Shure: We could play Naraka Bladepoint.
Jake:好好好行了行了
Jake: Okay, okay, that's fine.
Shure: 这时候赶紧给我们的网易打个广告
Shure: Now's a good time to advertise for NetEase.
Jake:挺好挺好
Jake: That's nice, that's nice.
Jake:这样好
Jake: This is good.
Shure: 这是干嘛的呀
Shure: What's this for?
Lucia: 做引体向上的哈哈哈
Lucia: To do pull-ups, hahaha.
Katrina: 做引体销售
Katrina: To do pull-up sales.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 挂个杆然后做引体向上是吗
Shure: Hang a bar and do pull-ups, right?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:行行行挺好挺好
Jake: Okay, okay, that's nice, that's nice.
Shure: 能能成功吗
Shure: Can it succeed?
Choiszt: 这正好因为我
Choiszt: That's perfect for me.
Jake:挺好挺好挺好挺好
Jake: That's nice, that's nice, that's nice, that's nice.
Lucia: 我们乱说的
Lucia: We're just kidding.
Lucia: 小心一点
Lucia: Be careful.
Choiszt: 你帮我
Choiszt: You help me.
Shure: 主要我撑不起来
Shure: Mainly, I can't hold up.
Choiszt: 这儿国外的我换的
Choiszt: This is from abroad, I swapped it.
Choiszt: 这电脑网状盘
Choiszt: This computer network disk.
Shure: 需要给他修剪吗
Shure: Do you need to trim it for him?
Choiszt: 最高两个
Choiszt: At most two.
Katrina: 随便你你的话
Katrina: Whatever you want.
Lucia: 你想修的话可以修呀
Lucia: If you want to trim it, you can.
Jake:也不用那么高
Jake: No need to make it so high.
Shure: 我不修因为我姓
Shure: I won't trim because I...
Jake:就你就卡到这就行
Jake: Just clip it here and it’s fine.
Shure: 修了一下
Shure: Trimmed a bit.
Lucia: 哦哦
Lucia: Oh, oh.
Alice:不缺修
Alice: No need to trim.
Jake:高了我怕他摔
Jake: Too high, I'm afraid he'll fall.
Choiszt: 昂
Choiszt: Hmm.
Jake:你看这个就是我的床的入口
Jake: Look, this is the entrance to my bed.
Lucia: 为什么这几个球球到现在还没有开
Lucia: Why haven't these balls opened yet?
Jake:全自动全自动入口你说
Jake: Fully automatic, fully automatic entrance, you said.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 你能过来吗
Shure: Can you come over here?
Jake:哈哈哈能啊这个一跳我就上上床
Jake: Hahaha, sure, I can just jump right up to bed.
Shure: 这么大地
Shure: It's so big.
Choiszt: 运行所有空间
Choiszt: Runs all the space.
Jake:对上床入口
Jake: Yes, the bed entrance.
Shure: 我靠哎呦喂sorry
Shure: Oh my god, oh wow, sorry.
Lucia: sorry一跳就上涨了可爱笑
Lucia: Sorry, just one jump and you're up, so cute.
Jake:对哈哈对对对入口
Jake: Yeah, hahaha, right, right, the entrance.
Katrina: 嗯理想中的房间
Katrina: Hmm, the ideal room.
Katrina: 哈哈哈学习完倒头就睡
Katrina: Hahaha, finish studying and just fall asleep right away.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:饶了我吧哈哈哈
Jake: Spare me, hahaha.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This...
Lucia: 这个确实是软件工程理想中的房间了
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 对写完代码直接倒头就睡
Katrina: Yeah, finish coding and just fall asleep.
Jake:哎盘呢
Jake: Hey, where's the disk?
Lucia: 啊哪哪个
Lucia: Huh, which one?
Jake:哦哦哦对对对刚刚对刚刚
Jake: Oh, oh, right, right, just now, just now.
Lucia: 刚拿过来的这个吗
Lucia: The one we just brought over?
Katrina: 哎二楼这投影仪也可以
Katrina: Hey, the projector on the second floor is pretty good too.
Katrina: 那款放点music可以吗
Katrina: Can we play some music on that one?
Jake:对一楼也是
Shure: 来电music
Shure: Play some music.
Katrina: yes反正戴了眼镜了
Katrina: Yes, since we're all wearing glasses anyway.
Jake:来点music
Jake: Play some music.
Katrina: 已经录下来
Katrina: It's already recording.
Jake:你们你们要现在是要干啥呀按照
Jake: What are you guys planning to do now?
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Katrina: 我们可以讨论一下
Katrina: We could discuss.
Katrina: 我们的那个房间装饰
Katrina: Our room decoration.
Katrina: 你不说要录录录下来吗
Katrina: Didn't you say you wanted to record it?
Jake:对对然后这个他们应该
Jake: Yeah, right, and then they should...
Jake:他说是4五点会有人过来收拾
Jake: He said someone will come around 4 or 5 to tidy up.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:对然后那会收拾
Jake: Yeah, and then they'll clean up.
Jake:收拾完我们就扫房间
Jake: Once they're done, we'll sweep the room.
Jake:就是扫3D扫
Jake: Like, do a 3D sweep.
Jake:嗯对我靠
Jake: Hmm, yeah, oh man.
Jake:4399 呵呵呵
Jake: 4399, hahaha.
Katrina: 那几点准备食材呢
Katrina: So when do we start prepping the ingredients?
Jake:呃对那要不现在就开始准备食材吧
Jake: Uh, how about we start prepping the ingredients now?
Shure: 死神vs火影
Shure: Bleach vs. Naruto.
Shure: 这不得来一把
Shure: We gotta play a round.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Choiszt: 房间里面
Choiszt: Inside the room.
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: It's all good.
Jake:对现在开始准备食材
Jake: Yeah, let's start prepping the ingredients now.
Jake:就现在就看一看
Jake: Let's take a look now.
Jake:准备准备
Jake: Let's prepare.
Katrina: 现在也可以看那个房间装饰购买
Katrina: We can also check out the room decor and make purchases now.
Jake:也可以
Jake: Sure.
Katrina: 然后5点他来收拾然后扫房间
Katrina: Then at 5, they'll clean and we'll sweep the room.
Katrina: 我们只需要稍微
Katrina: We just need to...
Tasha: 把我的也修一下吧
Tasha: Fix mine too, please.
Katrina: 收拾一下我们就下来忙这个呗
Katrina: Tidy up a bit, then we'll come down and work on this.
Jake:可以
Jake: Got it.
Katrina: 对扫房间
Katrina: Yeah, sweep the room.
Katrina: 扫房间是你们三个弄是吧
Katrina: You three will handle the sweeping, right?
Jake:呃这打扫房间是不是
Jake: Uh, is this cleaning the room?
Tasha:要么
Tasha: Or...
Tasha: 垃圾全部都放到我的行李箱
Tasha: Put all the trash in my suitcase.
Jake:嗯不用不用
Jake: No, no need.
Jake:我们都不用弄
Jake: We don't need to do that.
Katrina: OK那我们那个吧
Katrina: OK, then we'll...
Tasha: 是那你先放也行
Tasha: You can put it first if you want.
Katrina: 我看我要买什么
Katrina: I'll see what I need to buy.
Jake:OK来关掉4399
Jake: OK, let's turn off 4399.
Katrina: 我想买那我想搞成那种森林主题
Katrina: I want to buy it, I want to do a forest theme.
Jake:然后那个上上卡
Jake: And then put the card on.
Lucia: 我我没想好我要怎么样
Lucia: I haven't decided what I want yet.
Katrina: 搞全绿色
Katrina: Make it all green.
Lucia: 我想我想借一个同学的作业抄一下
Lucia: I want to borrow a classmate's homework to copy.
Alice:我本来想弄蓝的哈哈
Alice: I originally wanted to make it blue, haha.
Alice:后来发现蓝的太难买
Alice: But then I found out blue is too hard to find.
Alice:然后昨天晚上也挑了绿的
Alice: So last night I picked green.
Katrina: 也可以搞那种极简的
Katrina: You could go for something minimalist too.
Jake:为什么是这个
Jake: Why this one?
Katrina: 就那种无印良品风也行吧
Katrina: Like a Muji style would work too.
Alice:我先找一堆绿的我喜欢
Alice: I'll start by finding a bunch of greens I like.
Katrina: 你房间有那个钩子吗
Katrina: Do you have those hooks in your room?
Alice:青一点的绿
Alice: A lighter green.
Katrina: 就是我房间有两个钩子
Katrina: I have two hooks in my room.
Katrina: 我感觉可以买那种挂画海报呢
Katrina: I think you could buy those hanging posters.
Choiszt: 我擦你在里边放的啥
Choiszt: Damn, what did you put in there?
Katrina: 因为他不给贴
Katrina: Because they don't let you stick things.
Shure: 这样吧我们建一个歌单
Shure: How about we make a playlist?
Shure: 然后大家一人报一个歌名好吧
Shure: And everyone can suggest a song, okay?
Choiszt: 型号是哎从这儿
Choiszt: The model is, oh, from here.
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina: 大家可以想听什么自己输进去
Katrina: Everyone can input the songs they want to hear.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Nicous: 我这儿从12开始搞
Nicous: I'll start from number 12 here.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 然后我们搞随机播放
Katrina: Then we can shuffle play.
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 哇有点像那个随机舞蹈了哈哈
Katrina: Wow, it's kind of like random dance, haha.
Shure: 来大家先一人说一个歌名
Shure: Alright, everyone, suggest a song.
Shure: 我先都不放
Shure: I'll start, but I won't play anything yet.
Shure: 然后都加到歌单里
Shure: Then we'll add them to the playlist.
Choiszt: 这么又校准开始
Choiszt: This is how you calibrate and start.
Shure: 然后这个歌单随便放可以吧
Shure: Then we can play the playlist randomly, okay?
Lucia: 上
Lucia: Go ahead.
Katrina: 想听的歌
Katrina: The songs you want to hear.
Lucia: 我打开我的apple music
Lucia: I'll open my Apple Music.
Katrina: 好有意思啊
Katrina: This is so interesting.
Lucia: 然后突然发现
Lucia: And then suddenly I realize
Lucia: 我的我的APP账号没登在里面
Lucia: My app account isn't logged in.
Jake:我操没关系没关系没关系没关系
Jake: Damn, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 所以找不到自己签的歌单了
Lucia: So I can't find my signed playlist.
Lucia: 我得重新登录一下
Lucia: I need to log in again.
Jake:我我我觉
Jake: I, I, I think...
Shure: 你要什么
Shure: What do you need?
Lucia: 嗯邵瑞
Lucia: Hmm, Shure
Katrina: 来一首那个陶喆的爱很简单
Katrina: Let's sing that David Tao's "Love is Simple"
Jake:11号
Jake: Number 11
Shure: 爱很简单真的吗
Shure: "Love is Simple," really?
Jake:看一看你看一看
Jake: Take a look, take a look
Jake:看看这里面是什么
Jake: See what's inside
Katrina: 哇这首歌每次都是演唱会的压轴
Katrina: Wow, this song is always the highlight of concerts
Jake:他难道会这有人换吗
Jake: Can he really do it? Is there a replacement?
Shure: 陶喆
Shure: David Tao
Jake:1号没人
Jake: No one for number 1
Shure: 哦好像
Shure: Oh, looks like
Jake:换换下来就是这个
Jake: Swap it, then it's this one
Katrina: 肯定听过
Katrina: You've definitely heard it
Jake:看看有没有
Jake: Check if we have it
Shure: 不是没有陶喆版本
Shure: No, we don't have David Tao's version
Jake:东西万一要是原来送一个256
Jake: What if it was originally sent as a 256
Katrina: 啊你没有VIP是吗
Katrina: Ah, you don't have VIP, right?
Shure: 啊这个带的都好
Shure: Ah, this one fits well
Shure: 好先不慌
Shure: Okay, don't rush
Shure: 先加入歌单
Shure: Add it to the playlist first
Shure: 收藏一个
Shure: Save it
Katrina: 等会等会
Katrina: Wait, wait
Katrina: 这样拍张照好好
Katrina: Let's take a picture
Katrina: 有那种综艺的感觉
Katrina: It has that variety show feel
Shure: 是的还有什么
Shure: Yes, what else?
Lucia: 我我我点那个打雷姐的video games
Lucia: I, I, I want to pick that Lana Del Rey's "Video Games"
Shure: VEDD啊VIDD UVM
Shure: VEDD, uh, VIDD, UVM
Lucia: Kings
Katrina:  海报一直没调好
Katrina: The poster was never adjusted right
Shure: 这个是什么
Shure: What is this?
Jake:哎可以
Jake: Hey, this works
Tasha:啊好看
Tasha: Ah, it looks good
Lucia: 拉娜德雷的对
Lucia: Lana Del Rey's, yes
Jake:这电脑有吗
Jake: Does this computer have it?
Jake:一样
Jake: Same
Choiszt: 应该每个电脑都有
Choiszt: Every computer should have it
Jake:右边没有吗
Jake: Not on the right side?
Shure: 还有什么
Shure: What else?
Lucia: 然后还有什么
Lucia: And what else?
Jake:不是不是他
Jake: No, no, he
Alice:蝴蝶
Alice: Butterfly
Jake:你左边没有吗
Jake: Don't you have one on your left?
Shure: 蝴蝶谁的
Shure: Whose butterfly is it?
Katrina: 谁的蝴蝶
Katrina: Whose butterfly?
Alice:淘集集
Alice: Taobao
Katrina: 你也喜欢这首歌吗
Katrina: Do you like this song too?
Lucia: 哇哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:我挺喜欢的
Alice: I quite like it.
Katrina: 这是我超喜欢的一首歌
Katrina: This is one of my favorite songs.
Jake:我靠哈哈哈哈哈耶
Jake: Oh my gosh, hahaha, yeah!
Katrina: 我当时当时分手的时候狂听这首歌
Katrina: I listened to this song a lot when I broke up.
Shure: 还有什么
Shure: What else?
Jake:我毫无encounter呢
Jake: I had no encounter.
Lucia: 诶薇薇呢
Lucia: Hey, where's Tasha?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Alice:上去收拾东西喽
Alice: Let's go clean up.
Jake:毫无encounter
Jake: No encounter.
Lucia: 啊她还没有报报歌
Lucia: Ah, she hasn't reported her song yet.
Katrina: 搞那个我最近喜欢听那个张璇的
Katrina: Recently, I've been listening to Zhang Xuan.
Shure: 我的宝贝宝贝
Shure: My darling, darling.
Katrina:  我看个业火
Katrina: I'll watch some Karma.
Shure: 咋给输
Shure: How do we input it?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina: 你你要跳舞吗哈哈哈
Katrina: Are you going to dance? Hahaha.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Choiszt: 看完了在在呢个校准
Choiszt: After watching, we'll calibrate.
Shure: 最出圈的是吧
Shure: The most popular one, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:那个应该是被我清掉了
Jake: That one should have been cleared by me.
Jake:卡不也也行吧
Jake: The card is fine, right?
Jake:但是很蠢
Jake: But it's dumb.
Shure: 你刚刚说的什么
Shure: What did you just say?
Katrina: 我刚说的是什么
Katrina: What did I just say?
Jake:就是这些不统一
Jake: These are not unified.
Lucia: 我点一个音乐剧里面哈哈爱雷克栽培还累挺
Lucia: I'll pick one from a musical, haha, Eric Zephyr, still tired.
Jake:14个 256的和一个128的
Jake: 14 of 256GB and one 128GB.
Katrina: 不知道说什么
Katrina: I don't know what to say.
Katrina: 我感觉我的记忆有点
Katrina: I feel like my memory is...
Katrina: 就是7秒钟不知道说什么
Katrina: It's like I don't know what to say for 7 seconds.
Shure: 嗨嗨没有他是这么拼的吧
Shure: Hey, hey, isn't it spelled like this?
Jake:对对对今晚加个班
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, let's work overtime tonight.
Lucia: 对的对的对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure: 这个是吧
Shure: This one, right?
Lucia: 就就开场那首吧
Lucia: The opening song, right?
Katrina: 焰火
Katrina: Fireworks.
Lucia: 咋开
Lucia: How do we start?
Shure: 焰火
Shure: Fireworks.
Jake:哎那个你你们你们排一下
Jake: Hey, you guys, can you arrange it?
Shure: 还有人要点歌吗
Shure: Is anyone requesting a song?
Jake:等等一下等一下
Jake: Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Lucia: 有人要点歌吗
Lucia: Is anyone requesting a song?
Lucia: 3位要点歌吗
Lucia: Do the three of you want to request a song?
Jake:那不知羞硕的事情吗点歌
Jake: Isn't that Shure's job, taking song requests?
Choiszt: 点什么
Choiszt: Request what?
Lucia: 点歌
Lucia: Request a song.
Choiszt: 谁要弹
Choiszt: Who's going to play?
Lucia: 不是要放是要弹
Lucia: No, not playing, I mean performing.
Choiszt: 刚才放
Choiszt: Just now play.
Lucia: 要不要不让修硕谈哈
Lucia: How about letting Shure play?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  当安排
Katrina: As arranged.
Choiszt: 当他们他们反应过来就就是
Choiszt: When they react, it's like...
Shure: 啊安普啊呜
Shure: Uh, Amp, ah, oh.
Katrina: 最近很喜欢他
Katrina: Recently, I really like him.
Jake:等一下等一下等一下
Jake: Wait, wait, wait.
Katrina: 就是晚上一个人把那个
Katrina: It's like at night, someone puts on that...
Jake:哎听我指挥
Jake: Hey, listen to my command.
Katrina: 但是这房间隔音不太好
Katrina: But this room isn't well soundproofed.
Jake:大家听我指挥
Jake: Everyone, listen to my command.
Katrina: 估计大家也听到放那个歌特好听
Katrina: I guess everyone can hear the song, it's really good.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
Jake:呃首先这个东西它在它是
Jake: Uh, first of all, this thing, it is...
Shure: 安抚还
Shure: Comforting, still.
Jake:哎为什么在我手上
Jake: Hey, why is it in my hand?
Katrina: 我看好像是安普
Katrina: I think it's Amp.
Choiszt: 嗯
Choiszt: Hmm.
Jake:为什么在我手上
Jake: Why is it in my hand?
Choiszt: 在你新的
Choiszt: It's new to you.
Jake:11号是吧
Jake: Number 11, right?
Katrina: 呀涉及到知识
Katrina: Yeah, involves knowledge.
Katrina: 网球查一下吧
Katrina: Check the tennis.
Jake:是10一号吗
Jake: Is it number 10?
Shure: 不会拼那个哎
Shure: I can't spell that.
Katrina:  三轮
Katrina: Third round.
Katrina:  埃里克
Katrina: Eric.
Jake:别弄乱了弄乱傻逼了
Jake: Don't mess it up, you'll mess it up and look stupid.
Choiszt: 我不弄乱
Choiszt: I won't mess it up.
Jake:这个这个给我
Jake: Give me this one.
Choiszt: 本来我直接把这个卡卡上去一块
Choiszt: I was going to just put this card on here together.
Katrina: 是念谱吧
Katrina: Is it reading the score?
Shure: 念普
Shure: Reading the score.
Choiszt: 把这个把那两个换成这个
Choiszt: Replace those two with this one.
Choiszt: 长了7
Choiszt: It's been 7 days.
Jake:厂
Jake: Factory.
Shure: 连休
Shure: Continuous leave.
Katrina: 啊这首好听
Katrina: Ah, this song is nice.
Jake:好这样这个这个是1111是空的
Jake: Okay, so this one, this one is 1111 and it's empty.
Shure: 这前两天刚回归网易云
Shure: It just returned to NetEase Cloud a couple of days ago.
Tasha: 嗯拍照去了
Tasha: Hmm, took a photo.
Jake:不管他然后你你这边手上是什么
Jake: Doesn't matter, then what's in your hand?
Lucia: 那我点那个滚石的
Lucia: Then I'll play that Rolling Stones one.
Lucia: 不是滚石枪花的希文沃
Lucia: No, the Guns N' Roses one, Steven Adler.
Lucia: 哈哈超喜欢这个
Lucia: Haha, I love this one.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh my.
Jake:还没有一张还没有
Jake: Not a single one yet.
Lucia: 突然想起来
Lucia: Suddenly remembered.
Jake:行这样吧
Jake: Okay, let's do it this way.
Jake:就是你这二楼的
Jake: So you handle the second floor.
Shure: 这才是老摇滚
Shure: This is real rock.
Jake:呃视频主搞一楼的好吧
Jake: Uh, the video host handles the first floor, okay?
Shure: 嗯嗯嗯
Shure: Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Choiszt: 他这个视频
Choiszt: This video.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 经常在听老歌
Lucia: I often listen to old songs.
Jake:你你不用
Jake: You don't need to.
Jake:就是首先你下一个下一个
Jake: So first of all, next one, next one.
Katrina: 大家的风格都完全不一样
Katrina: Everyone's style is completely different.
Jake:VLC VLC VLC VLC啊
Jake: VLC, VLC, VLC, VLC, ah.
Shure: 谁刚刚没有点歌来着要点歌
Shure: Who hasn't chosen a song yet and wants to choose?
Lucia: 微微点歌吗
Lucia: Is Tasha choosing a song?
Katrina: 他点了蝴蝶
Katrina: He picked "Butterfly."
Tasha: 我吗
Tasha: Me?
Katrina: 哦那个我也点过
Katrina: Oh, I picked that one too.
Shure: 蝴蝶点过了
Shure: "Butterfly" has already been picked.
Lucia: 嗯对
Lucia: Yeah, that's right.
Lucia: 你还你还你
Lucia: You still, you still, you...
Lucia: 还没点应该
Lucia: Haven't picked yet, right?
Shure: 还有谁没点
Shure: Who else hasn't picked?
Katrina:  有啥想听的歌吗
Katrina: Is there any song you want to hear?
Tasha: 路亚要点一首是吗
Tasha: Is Luyue going to pick one?
Choiszt: 哎你想听陈奕迅吗
Choiszt: Hey, do you want to hear Eason Chan?
Lucia: 对也可以多点
Lucia: Yeah, we can pick more of his songs.
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:这边要点陈奕迅
Jake: We're picking Eason Chan over here.
Choiszt: 来首陈奕迅的
Choiszt: Let's pick an Eason Chan song.
Lucia: 两首可以点哪个浮夸
Lucia: We can pick two songs, how about "Exaggerated"?
Katrina: 来首陈奕迅的
Katrina: Let's pick an Eason Chan song.
Nicous: 来个来几首周杰伦
Nicous: Let's pick a few Jay Chou songs.
Tasha: 我手机呢
Tasha: Where's my phone?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 周杰伦没有我是
Shure: There's no Jay Chou, I'm...
Lucia: 陈奕迅和周杰伦
Lucia: Eason Chan and Jay Chou.
Katrina: 我想听那个爱是一本书
Katrina: I want to hear "Love is a Book."
Katrina: 就是陈奕迅的爱是一本书
Katrina: It's Eason Chan's "Love is a Book."
Choiszt: 这是什么
Choiszt: What's that?
Shure: 爱是一本书OK
Shure: "Love is a Book," okay.
Nicous: 干嘛呢
Nicous: What are you doing?
Jake:哎你这怎么
Jake: Hey, what are you...
Choiszt: 这这么插也插不上
Choiszt: This, this won't connect.
Shure: 这个是吗
Shure: Is it this one?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: ok
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 我也来帮陈奕迅点一个 浮夸
Lucia: I'll help pick an Eason Chan song too, "Exaggerated."
Jake:哎呦哎呦卧槽
Jake: Oh wow, oh wow, damn.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:卧槽你你是几天没睡觉的
Jake: Damn, how many days have you not slept?
Choiszt: 我擦你这容易把我的把我的撕了
Choiszt: Damn, you're gonna tear mine apart.
Shure: OK先
Shure: Okay, first...
Katrina:  符号填什么什么什么什么
Katrina: What symbols should we fill in?
Jake:呃你你等啊
Jake: Uh, you wait.
Jake:你你拧一下
Jake: You twist it.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha!
Shure: 我擦
Shure: Damn.
Jake:拧一下你拧一下
Jake: Twist it, twist it.
Choiszt: 好
Choiszt: Alright.
Jake:好你你是谁
Jake: Okay, who are you?
Shure: 特殊事宜
Shure: Special business.
Nicous: 啊
Nicous: Ah.
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake: What do you want to do?
Nicous: 我要下这个mMP4
Nicous: I want to download this MP4.
Jake:OK你现在电脑里面
Jake: Okay, what’s on your computer now?
Katrina: 这是什么软件
Katrina: What software is this?
Jake:你你现在电脑里面是什么旗号
Jake: What’s the name on your computer now?
Katrina: 做音乐的
Katrina: Music-making.
Shure: 脑子已经快佩柔
Shure: My brain is almost soft.
Choiszt: 我现在7号
Choiszt: I’m on number 7 now.
Jake:旗号拔出来先
Jake: Remove the label first.
Jake:不要旗号
Jake: No label.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Katrina: 确实我觉得网易云唯一不足
Katrina: Honestly, I think the only drawback of NetEase Cloud is
Katrina: 就是没有周杰伦
Katrina: there's no Jay Chou.
Katrina: 就是你得切另一个软件
Katrina: You have to switch to another software.
Lucia: 啊是
Lucia: Ah, yes.
Lucia: 网易云上压根就没啊OK
Lucia: NetEase Cloud doesn’t have it at all, okay.
Shure: 没有那个版权
Shure: They don't have the license.
Shure: 来吧随机播放
Shure: Come on, shuffle play.
Shure: 第一首先放哪个
Shure: Which one to play first?
Jake:这个其实咱装可以
Jake: Actually, we can install this.
Jake:没问题没问题没问题
Jake: No problem, no problem, no problem.
Shure: 就先放你这个吧好吧
Shure: Let's play yours first, okay?
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm, yeah.
Katrina: 然后你按随机看你这音效效果怎么样
Katrina: Then you press shuffle and see how the sound effects are.
Jake:7号
Jake: Number 7.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:对然后呃西明珠从1号开始稍微容
Jake: Right, then uh, starting from number 1 for Ximingzhu.
Shure: 嗯没声音
Shure: Hmm, no sound.
Lucia: 谁的有谁的电话吗这是
Lucia: Whose phone is this?
Jake:易一点对你你稍微难一点
Jake: A bit easier, you take it a bit harder.
Tasha: 啊我手机居然在这里
Tasha: Ah, my phone is actually here.
Jake:哈哈哈你从你从9号开始
Jake: Hahaha, you start from number 9.
Shure: 这是我原来乐队的名字
Shure: This was the name of my old band.
Jake:8号在一楼
Jake: Number 8 is on the first floor.
Jake:呃9号
Jake: Uh, number 9.
Katrina:  我还以为内个喊得握
Katrina: I thought it was someone else shouting.
Jake:对十一号跳过去
Jake: Yeah, skip to number 11.
Choiszt: 这新买的红色的是啊啊
Choiszt: This new red one is, right?
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:然后你们要做的事情是把每一层
Jake: Then what you need to do is for each floor...
Jake:就是按楼层
Jake: By floor...
Jake:这个是一楼
Jake: This is the first floor.
Katrina: 哇对味
Katrina: Wow, that's the smell.
Jake:哎这是一楼
Jake: Yep, this is the first floor.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay.
Jake:这是二楼
Jake: This is the second floor.
Katrina: 爽啦
Katrina: Awesome.
Jake:然后我标一下
Jake: Then let me mark it.
Jake:给我一个那个纸
Jake: Give me that paper.
Choiszt: 要拿内个纸啊对
Choiszt: Need to take that paper, right.
Jake:还能是谁哈哈
Jake: Who else could it be, haha?
Choiszt: 是吧内什么3言2号线超充板
Choiszt: Right, that 3Y2 line supercharged board.
Jake:对啊郝哲
Jake: Yeah, Haozhe.
Katrina: 哎呀怎么把我网名念出来了
Katrina: Oh no, you said my online name.
Katrina: 哈哈哈因为
Katrina: Hahaha, because...
Jake:呵为什么还在3月2号
Jake: Why is it still on March 2nd?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Lucia: 太激动了不想改
Lucia: Too excited, don't want to change it.
Jake:等到明年3月2号是吧
Jake: Wait until March 2nd next year, right?
Katrina: 等到什么时候再看下一场了再改
Katrina: Wait until the next show to change it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Choiszt: 直接看索卡尔的
Choiszt: Just watch Sokar's.
Katrina: 对我看第一场
Katrina: Yeah, I'll watch the first show.
Katrina: 在武汉我抢到了前驱票
Katrina: I got the front-row ticket in Wuhan.
Nicous: 那个时候我好像还在武汉
Nicous: I think I was still in Wuhan then.
Katrina: 3月2号 哦
Katrina: March 2nd, oh.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 那时候刚来学校一会
Katrina: Just got to school then.
Lucia: sorry哈哈哈
Lucia: Sorry, hahaha.
Choiszt: 一丹和陈奕迅差差的10来岁
Choiszt: Yidan and Eason Chan have about a 10-year age difference.
Katrina: 但是但是
Katrina: But, but...
Katrina: 他现在嗓子已经回春很多了
Katrina: His voice has really rejuvenated a lot now.
Katrina: 他把那心乱肺的高音给飙上去
Katrina: He hit that insanely high note.
Jake:那就整整火锅呗
Jake: Let's make some hotpot then.
Jake:然后聊一聊你们
Jake: And then let's chat about you guys.
Katrina: 了OK
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina: 我要买一下我的东西
Katrina: I need to buy my stuff.
Jake:好让数据丰富起来
Jake: Alright, let's make the data richer.
Katrina: 今天可丰富了
Katrina: There's plenty today.
Lucia: 我
Katrina: 今天还那么多肢体动作
Katrina: So many gestures today.
Jake:确实对现在也要丰富起来
Jake: Yeah, let's enrich it now.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Alice:给你剪
Alice: I'll cut it for you.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina: 哎我靠真好看
Katrina: Wow, it looks great.
Lucia: 到现在还没想好买啥
Lucia: I still haven't decided what to buy.
Katrina: 其实现在好多那种
Katrina: Actually, nowadays there are many...
Katrina: 就是那种很有意思的做的家居品牌
Katrina: ...many interesting home decor brands.
Lucia: 我选一个整屋定制哈哈哈
Lucia: I'm going for a whole house customization, haha.
Katrina: 好好看哈哈
Katrina: It looks so good, haha.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization.
Katrina: 你让杨老板给你报销
Katrina: Have Jake reimburse you.
Jake:外包是吧
Jake: Outsourcing, right?
Lucia: 对对对哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, haha.
Jake:外包呵呵
Jake: Outsourcing, haha.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization.
Jake:500块钱 200外包
Jake: 500 bucks, 200 outsourcing.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:全程外包
Jake: Fully outsourced.
Lucia: 给我点纸
Lucia: Give me some tissues.
Jake:不是不是VLC啊
Jake: No, no, not VLC.
Jake:你这哪个VLC
Jake: Which VLC are you using?
Lucia: 因为这种对于我这个选择恐惧症来说
Lucia: Because for someone with choice anxiety like me,
Jake:你这不是VLC
Jake: This isn't VLC.
Jake:你们这这个啊
Jake: This one is...
Lucia: 真的很难搞
Lucia: It's really hard.
Katrina: 我还有一个小阳台
Katrina: I also have a small balcony.
Katrina: 我阳台上可以放东西
Katrina: I can put stuff on my balcony.
Jake:对对对video nine
Jake: Yeah, yeah, video nine.
Jake:这个是你
Jake: This one is you.
Jake:你瞎盗版了
Jake: You pirated it blindly.
Katrina: 非非无法抉择哦哦
Katrina: Fifi can't decide, oh oh.
Jake:哈哈哈学学
Jake: Hahaha, learn from it.
Jake:挺准的你
Jake: You got it pretty accurate.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:呃这样你你跟他一样
Jake: Uh, like this, you are like him.
Jake:但是你这个可能不太稳
Jake: But this might not be very stable.
Jake:不知道怎么办
Jake: I don't know what to do.
Jake:你腰部也低一点
Jake: Lower your waist a bit too.
Tasha: 哈哈减无可减
Tasha: Hahaha, can't cut anymore.
Jake:然后这个高一点
Jake: And this, raise it a bit.
Jake:我想想怎么办
Jake: Let me think about what to do.
Jake:因为
Jake: Because...
Jake:因为你这个硬盘也要放在这个地方
Jake: Because you need to put the hard drive here too.
Jake:然后但是这个硬盘你你不能摔着
Jake: But you can't drop this hard drive.
Jake:你懂吗所以你行行行
Jake: You understand? So, okay, okay.
Jake:哈哈哈对然后插上
Jake: Hahaha, yeah, then plug it in.
Katrina: 有一种岁月静好的感觉
Katrina: There's a feeling of peace and quiet.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 他们在工作
Katrina: They're working.
Lucia: 要不然我搞个照片墙
Lucia: How about I make a photo wall?
Katrina: 然后这边在放歌
Katrina: And play music over here.
Katrina: 这边在剪花
Katrina: Cutting flowers over here.
Shure: 我给你们加油打气
Shure: I'll cheer you guys on.
Shure: 我给你们跳yes okay
Shure: I'll do a "yes okay" dance for you.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎
Lucia: Hahaha, hey.
Jake:对唔出
Jake: Yeah, spit it out.
Lucia: 我觉得他动作已经很得精髓了
Lucia: I think he really got the essence of it.
Jake:要不把碗洗了哈哈哈
Jake: How about you wash the dishes? Hahaha.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:先生你好
Jake: Hello, sir.
Jake:卧槽哈哈哈你怎么弄的
Jake: Whoa, hahaha, how did you do that?
Choiszt: 这个盘这个盘
Choiszt: This dish, this dish.
Jake:呃OK
Jake: Uh, okay.
Jake:那那你直接这样嘛
Jake: Then, then just do it like this.
Jake:你你觉得怎么样
Jake: What do you think?
Katrina: get up
Katrina: Get up.
Jake:能能贴吗贴着吧
Jake: Can you stick it? Stick it.
Jake:这拿打着
Jake: Hold it like this.
Jake:不行歇着歇着好
Jake: No, no, take a break, take a break.
Jake:oh
Jake: Oh
Jake:拿个工具
Jake: Get a tool.
Jake:先贴硬盘
Jake: Attach the hard drive first.
Jake:哎呦卧槽
Jake: Whoa, damn!
Jake:呵呵呵挺好
Jake: Haha, pretty good.
Jake:没事没事
Jake: No problem, no problem.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: Not a big deal.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:哦那你看怎么贴
Jake: Oh, see how you attach it?
Lucia: 飘窗柜好像很有用的鸭子
Lucia: Bay window cabinet seems very useful.
Jake:你弄矮一点
Jake: Make it a bit lower.
Choiszt: 很稳
Choiszt: Very stable.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:那贴一个
Jake: Then attach one.
Jake:等一下贴硬盘上 1 2
Jake: Wait a moment, attach it to the hard drive, 1, 2.
Katrina: 天呐好多好看的都是要做手工
Katrina: Oh my, so many pretty ones need to be handmade.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 啊直接到浮夸了
Katrina: Ah, straight to being flamboyant.
Jake:教外国人用淘宝也挺好
Jake: Teaching foreigners to use Taobao is pretty good too.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:让他们羡慕去
Jake: Let them envy us.
Lucia: 有哪个购物平台给咱给赞助吗
Lucia: Is there any shopping platform sponsoring us?
Lucia: 就多用用他们的
Lucia: We could use them more often.
Jake:这还有个帽子还戴着呢哈
Jake: There's a hat here, still wearing it, huh?
Lucia: 啊亚马逊是吗
Lucia: Oh, Amazon, right?
Lucia: 他们已经会用了不用教
Lucia: They already know how to use it, no need to teach.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Katrina: 我要买几个摆在我那
Katrina: I want to buy a few to place at my place.
Jake:这就直接导
Jake: This just directly leads.
Jake:自然前面的数据都不太好
Jake: Naturally, the previous data wasn't very good.
Choiszt: 都导出去导这个
Choiszt: Export all the data, export this.
Jake:呃这个
Jake: Uh, this one.
Katrina:  爽
Jake:你们这个硬盘里面贴这个
Jake: You attach this in the hard drive.
Choiszt: 哎这个直接这个2号是
Choiszt: Hey, this is directly, this is number 2.
Jake:暗号是第二层
Jake: The code is the second layer.
Jake:专门专门做Pro的第二层
Jake: Specifically, the Pro's second layer.
Jake:然后你按照每一个相机
Jake: And then you follow each camera.
Jake:呃然后每一天
Jake: Uh, and then each day.
Jake:哦哦哦哈哈
Jake: Oh oh oh, haha.
Jake:他会切自己会切
Jake: He can cut it himself.
Alice:还满意吗
Alice: Are you satisfied?
Tasha: 可以呀谢谢
Tasha: Yes, thank you.
Jake:呃我来跟你命名
Jake: Uh, let me name it for you.
Jake:看好看好
Jake: Watch closely.
Jake:然后这个先上
Jake: And then put this on first.
Jake:先上这个盘对吧
Jake: Put this plate on first, right?
Jake:这个这个盘
Jake: This, this plate.
Jake:好呃呃
Jake: Okay, uh, uh.
Jake:还没连上
Jake: Not connected yet.
Jake:连上
Jake: Connect it.
Jake:插上了这边
Jake: Plug it in here.
Jake:如果我原来帮他插上了
Jake: If I had plugged it in before.
Jake:然后你现在没有
Jake: And now you don't have it.
Jake:他要可热化一下
Jake: He wants to heat it up a bit.
Lucia: 不好唱的
Lucia: It's hard to sing.
Jake:搁搁哈哈哈
Jake: Put it, put it, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Choiszt: 这个
Choiszt: This.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 这锅是谁的个个
Shure: Whose pot is this?
Lucia: 抄作业了
Lucia: Copying homework.
Lucia: 哈哈没事
Lucia: Haha, it's okay.
Tasha: 什么都没干
Tasha: Didn't do anything.
Alice:那
Alice: Well.
Lucia: 你做作业
Lucia: You do your homework.
Lucia: 你放心的做作业
Lucia: You can do your homework with peace of mind.
Jake:然后放对
Jake: Then put it right.
Lucia: 啊好难过死
Lucia: Ah, so sad.
Jake:一般放个瓶
Jake: Usually put a bottle.
Lucia: 啊你剪的这个好漂亮呀
Lucia: Ah, what you cut is so pretty.
Alice:这都是我捡的
Alice: I picked all these.
Lucia: 啊这也好看
Lucia: Ah, this is also beautiful.
Lucia: 这面看特别有层次感
Lucia: This side looks particularly layered.
Lucia: 啊你的这个也还没开
Lucia: Ah, yours hasn't opened yet.
Alice:嗯还没有呢
Alice: Hmm, not yet.
Lucia: 我那个也是
Lucia: Mine too.
Lucia: 都还没开
Lucia: Still hasn't opened.
Alice:欣赏一下
Alice: Just appreciate it.
Jake:好看
Jake: Looks good.
Jake:是修剪了一遍
Jake: It's been trimmed once.
Alice:yes
Alice: Yes.
Jake:修剪了狠狠的修剪了一遍
Jake: Trimmed it, really gave it a thorough trim.
Alice:也没有还很一般般
Alice: But it's still pretty average.
Jake:确实好看了很多
Jake: It's definitely looking a lot better.
Lucia: 我好奇一下大家都写的什么符号
Lucia: I'm curious about what symbols everyone drew.
Alice:我给他画的翅膀
Alice: I drew wings for him.
Lucia: 小翅膀
Lucia: Little wings.
Alice:但是画的有点丑
Alice: But they turned out a bit ugly.
Jake:还没写写一下
Jake: Haven't written yet, go ahead and write.
Alice:我是个星
Alice: I drew a star.
Lucia: 我是个小太阳
Lucia: I drew a little sun.
Choiszt: 不是我是你一百多括号点
Choiszt: No, I drew over a hundred parentheses points.
Lucia: 啊雨轩是直接写的名字
Lucia: Oh, Yuxuan just wrote his name directly.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 哦香薰
Katrina: Oh, aromatherapy.
Katrina: 我想买个小香薰
Katrina: I want to buy a little aromatherapy.
Choiszt: 哎咋了
Choiszt: Hey, what's up?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Choiszt: 为啥他们说内个十一二
Choiszt: Why did they say that one was eleven or twelve?
Lucia: 买一串星星灯
Lucia: Buy a string of star lights.
Lucia: 直接给房间上挂一圈就完事了
Lucia: Just hang them around the room and that's it.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Nicous: 这个这个LRB能内个什么
Nicous: Can this LRB do that thing?
Jake:这是我的
Jake: This is mine.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Choiszt: 那导的过程中就完全没有就
Choiszt: So, during the guidance, there was completely no...
Katrina: 火
Katrina: Fire.
Katrina: 哈哈哈受不
Katrina: Hahaha, can't stand it?
Lucia: 他是什么花
Lucia: What kind of flower is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哇很直接了当
Lucia: Wow, very straightforward.
Jake:就是只要NB4 其他的都不用
Jake: As long as it's NB4, you don't need anything else.
Lucia: 剪了那么多
Lucia: Trimmed so much.
Jake:不用啊哎
Jake: No need, hey.
Jake:人呢他会吗
Jake: Is he capable?
Jake:尼玛哈哈哈你咋跑了
Jake: Oh my god, hahaha, why did you run away?
Jake:我回来了
Jake: I'm back.
Jake:哈哈哈你结束
Jake: Hahaha, you're done?
Choiszt: 昂我那我这儿已经结束了
Choiszt: Yeah, I'm done here.
Jake:尼玛不让你
Jake: Damn, I won't let you.
Jake:哈哈哈 15十五号
Jake: Hahaha, the 15th, the fifteenth.
Jake:十六号秒
Jake: The sixteenth second.
Choiszt: 我先我先移过去
Choiszt: Let me move over first.
Jake:你这是不是
Jake: Is this...
Lucia: 嗯点的什么
Lucia: Hmm, what did you order?
Jake:哎其实没毛病
Jake: Actually, it's not a problem.
Jake:哈哈哈多少慢了点
Jake: Hahaha, but it's a bit slow.
Jake:只是慢了
Jake: Just a bit slow.
Choiszt: 他内个最多差一个
Choiszt: His is only off by one at most.
Lucia: 这儿有水
Lucia: There's water here.
Shure: 这里有吧这里有
Shure: There's some here, right here.
Lucia: 啊谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks.
Jake:就一个硬盘啊
Jake: Just one hard drive?
Choiszt: 不是你这个这个
Choiszt: No, this, this one.
Alice: 没空
Alice: No time.
Jake:但是你速度我不知道
Jake: But your speed, I don't know.
Jake:你两个一起倒速度会有变化吗
Jake: Will the speed change if you pour both together?
Alice: 啊没事
Alice: Ah, it's okay.
Lucia: 嗯没有笔了吗
Lucia: Hmm, are there no more pens?
Jake:呃应该就是很讲究的命名方式
Jake: Uh, it should be a very specific naming method.
Shure: 这个面糊会不会堵下水道呢
Shure: Will this batter clog the drain?
Jake:是你呃你现在怎么命名呢
Jake: So, uh, how do you name it now?
Jake:来来来这个法2好吧
Jake: Come on, let's use method 2, okay?
Jake:那你写个一一一新建文件加一
Jake: Then create a new file and add one.
Jake:呃然后进去
Jake: Uh, then go in.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:进去新建一个202404
Jake: Go in and create a new one, 202404.
Jake:你直接建吧
Jake: Just create it directly.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Jake:到时候你看他创建日期是什么时候
Jake: Then check the creation date later.
Jake:他有自己的充电日期
Jake: It has its own charge date.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 照片墙
Lucia: Photo wall.
Jake:快速干嘛啊
Jake: Why so fast?
Jake:啊对这这够快了
Jake: Ah, yeah, that's fast enough.
Jake:比mac快多了
Jake:哎mac也很快
Jake:你可以你可以建很多
Jake: You can, you can create many.
Jake:你可以建到22
Jake: You can build it to 22.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 搞定
Shure: Done.
Shure: 全倍亮跟你讲
Shure: Full brightness, I'm telling you.
Alice: 等一下你这个内个内个
Alice: Wait a minute, this, this...
Jake:不用不用
Jake: No, no.
Jake:对啊我我觉得不应该这么办了
Jake: Yeah, I think we shouldn't do it this way.
Jake:气死我了
Jake: It's driving me crazy.
Jake:我原来想一个小时在这转一圈搞定
Jake: I originally thought one hour to circle around and get it done.
Jake:他妈头崩了
Jake: Damn, my head is about to explode.
Choiszt: 好的帅哥
Choiszt: Okay, handsome.
Shure: 啊搞定
Shure: Ah, done.
Jake:所以说我得插到GoPro
Jake: So I have to insert it into the GoPro.
Jake:就是把那个充电线给插电脑上
Jake: Just plug the charging cable into the computer.
Jake:然后开始倒
Jake: And then start transferring.
Jake:然后每一个一个一个跑
Jake: And then one by one.
Jake:就是原来的方案是推着这个小桌子
Jake: The original plan was to push this small table.
Choiszt: 嗷对对对这个歌确实是
Choiszt: Oh right, this song is really...
Jake:然后推着到处跑
Jake: And then push it around.
Jake:然后碰到傻逼了
Jake: And then we ran into an idiot.
Jake:哈哈哈太难了
Jake: Hahaha, it's so hard.
Nicous: 太慢了
Nicous: Too slow.
Shure: 在点什么
Shure: What are you ordering?
Jake:太慢了又慢又麻烦
Jake: Too slow, slow and troublesome.
Choiszt: 那咋了我擦那你这那你这
Choiszt: So what? Damn, what about this?
Choiszt: 看原来的帮不了你就这一个
Choiszt: See, the old ones can't help, there's only this one.
Jake:they are就两两个人
Jake: They are just two people.
Jake:好歹一人一层啊
Jake: At least one per floor.
Jake:我他妈一人15个
Jake: I'm taking care of 15 by myself.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 我要不要去搬俩凳子下来
Lucia: Should I bring down two chairs?
Lucia: 两个凳子啊
Lucia: Two chairs, right?
Lucia: 啊啥
Lucia: Huh?
Lucia: 我们是在上面还是下面
Lucia: Are we eating upstairs or downstairs?
Katrina: 现在在shoping
Katrina: We're shopping now.
Lucia: 如果在下面的话我就再搬俩凳子下来
Lucia: If it's downstairs, I'll bring down two more chairs.
Jake:好好在下面吃
Jake: Okay, let's eat downstairs.
Lucia: 那行
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 过来的
Lucia: Coming over.
Lucia: never were as you i not
Lucia: Never were as you, I not.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 哎呀
Lucia: Ah!
Shure: 他有自己的生命了
Shure: It has its own life.
Jake:对但是他不是赛博的
Jake: Yeah, but it's not cyber.
Jake:你是赛博的
Jake: You are cyber.
Shure: 那也就是现在
Shure: So, that means now...
Jake:呵呵哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Jake: Haha, hahahaha.
Shure: 就是凭空就有一个人
Shure: Someone just appeared out of nowhere.
Shure: 有一把吉他在这里自己发声是吗
Shure: Is there a guitar here that plays itself?
Lucia: 没事不用谢
Lucia: No worries, no need to thank me.
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 我们差差31234567然后我们有几个人
Lucia: We count 31234567, then how many people do we have?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 八个人再拿一个
Lucia: Eight people, get another one.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:I9号卡
Lucia: 嘿
Lucia: Hey.
Jake:刚刚是谁拿走的
Jake: Who just took it?
Jake:9号 海
Jake: Number 9, Sea.
Lucia: 丁
Choiszt: 9号在我这儿
Choiszt: Number 9 is with me.
Choiszt: 现在导的就是9号
Choiszt: Now it's number 9 leading.
Choiszt: 9号在我这儿在我这儿
Choiszt: Number 9 is with me, with me.
Choiszt: 在哪里点歌
Choiszt: Where do we request songs?
Shure: 有人跳海
Shure: Someone's dancing.
Choiszt: 有人有人相爱有人漂有人低音炮在作怪
Choiszt: Some people are in love, some are drifting, some have deep voices causing trouble.
Shure: 以点歌然后加入到歌单就好
Shure: Just request a song and add it to the playlist.
Jake:树确实爽多了啊
Jake: The tree indeed feels much better, huh.
Nicous: 直接把直接把这儿交了
Nicous: Just hand it over directly.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Nicous: 链接到易狗而且易狗的话
Nicous: Link it to E-Dog, and if it's E-Dog...
Shure: 对加入到歌单
Shure: Yes, add it to the playlist.
Shure: 然后放入到易狗里面
Shure: Then put it into E-Dog.
Nicous: 好我点你接
Nicous: Okay, I'll request, you handle it.
Shure: 就是你说那更多那块
Shure: It's where you said, that more section.
Nicous: 好
Nicous: Okay.
Shure: 然后收藏
Shure: Then bookmark it.
Shure: 然后到ego里面
Shure: 想想我们要干什么家人们
Shure: Think about what we should do, folks.
Lucia: 我们干什么
Lucia: What should we do?
Nicous: 比如说
Nicous: For example...
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Nicous: 看一下我做这个让以后AI还原
Nicous: Look at what I did, so AI can restore it later.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm
Choiszt: 哎不行我加完了我要重新点一下
Choiszt: Ah no, I added it, I need to click again.
Nicous: 学会了吗
Nicous: Got it?
Shure: 学会了
Shure: Got it.
Choiszt: 然后点yes啊
Choiszt: Then click yes.
Nicous: 我猜你会用
Nicous: I guess you can use it.
Choiszt: 我会翻绳
Choiszt: I can flip the rope.
Nicous: 不至于
Nicous: No way.
Choiszt: 来翻绳
Choiszt: Come flip the rope.
Nicous: 不至于不至于不至于
Nicous: No way, no way, no way.
Shure: 你们会翻绳吗
Shure: Can you guys flip the rope?
Choiszt: 会什么
Choiszt: Flip what?
Shure: 会翻绳吗
Shure: Can you flip the rope?
Choiszt: 会翻绳那有绳
Choiszt: Flip the rope, where's the rope?
Shure: 拿绳来
Shure: Bring the rope.
其他人：拿那个充电线
Shure: 咱们不至于这么赛博吧
Shure: We can't be this cyber, right?
Nicous: 拿这个充电线
Nicous: Use this charging cable.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm
Shure: 有没有棉线什么的
Shure: Do you have any cotton strings or something?
Choiszt: 没有没有
Choiszt: No, no.
Choiszt: 有绳吗
Choiszt: Is there any rope?
Nicous: 没有
Nicous: No.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Choiszt: 啊
Choiszt: Ah
Nicous: 把这个弦磨磨就开了
Nicous: Just grind this string and it will open.
Shure: 这是你的张轩
Shure: Is this your Zhang Xuan?
Katrina:  好好听呀
Katrina: Sounds so good.
Nicous: 我不会抽
Nicous: I can't smoke.
Jake:以房间装扮吗
Jake: Is it for room decoration?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Jake:房间装扮吗
Jake: Room decoration?
Shure: 我的房间好像没有什么太装扮的东西
Shure: My room doesn't seem to have much decoration.
Nicous: 靠我这这么这么慢
Nicous: Damn, I'm so slow.
Jake:多少啊
Jake: How much?
Tasha: 20
Choiszt: 快导完了哎你这为什么是
Choiszt: Almost done transferring, hey why is yours
Nicous: 我也不知道啊
Nicous: I don't know either.
Shure: 这个角落真的好好看
Shure: This corner looks really nice.
Jake:太难了
Jake: It's too hard.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Nicous: 几点了我槽
Nicous: What time is it, damn?
其他人：就是这个
其他人：go Pro晚上到几点
Nicous: 晚上给我戴个眼镜
Nicous: Put on glasses for me at night.
Nicous: 我戴个眼镜看一下会生什么
Nicous: I'll wear glasses to see what happens.
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:那你有热吧
Jake: Are you hot?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Nicous: 我见你也是可得有点长
Nicous: I've seen you for quite a while too.
Choiszt: 咱内管到12点
Choiszt: We manage until 12 o'clock.
Choiszt: 这把电脑来一下
Choiszt: Bring over that computer.
Nicous: 昨天来的狗
Nicous: The dog that came yesterday.
其他人：去看看内个狗
Shure: Let's go check out that dog.
Nicous: 家里窝铺
Nicous: The bed at home.
Choiszt: 行下一步我这么这么不是
Choiszt: Okay, next step, why not do it this way?
Jake:母狗
Jake: Female dog.
Choiszt: 有咖啡店
Choiszt: There's a coffee shop.
Nicous: 有一个咖啡店有一个小边牧
Nicous: There's a coffee shop with a little Border Collie.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  可以叫来玩吗
Katrina: Can we invite it to play?
Choiszt: 好像不能借走
Choiszt: Seems like we can't borrow it.
Nicous: 借过来然后呢
Nicous: Borrow it and then what?
Jake:扣扣
Jake: Knock, knock.
Choiszt: 但内个狗摸的好好好舒服
Choiszt: But that dog is so comfy to pet.
Katrina:  嗷我昨天看见他了在那里趴着
Katrina: Oh, I saw him yesterday, lying there.
Jake:嗷
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 我们昨天看见他的衣服了
Shure: We saw his clothes yesterday.
Katrina:  可以找他玩吗因为他曾在内个角落里趴着睡觉
Katrina: Can we play with him because he was lying in that corner sleeping?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:在那里
Jake: Over there.
Shure: 那我们去扒他衣服去
Shure: Let's go take his clothes off.
Choiszt: 不太远就在旁边内家咖啡厅
Choiszt: It's not far, just in that café nearby.
Katrina:  我去找他去玩吗
Katrina: Should I go look for him?
Jake:咖啡厅
Jake: The café.
Shure: 扒他裤子
Shure: Take his pants off.
Choiszt: 哎你这眼镜关了
Choiszt: Hey, your glasses turned off.
Jake:对已经关了
Jake: Yeah, they're off.
Jake:没电了应该
Jake: Probably out of battery.
Katrina:  没内存了
Katrina: No more memory.
Katrina:  我看看
Katrina: Let me check.
Jake:可能没电了
Jake: Could be out of battery.
Jake:sorry今天还在
Jake: Sorry, still recording today.
Shure: 应该是没电了
Shure: It's probably out of battery.
Choiszt: 没电这么办充电
Choiszt: What to do if it's out of battery?
Jake:插充电宝
Jake: Plug in the power bank.
Shure: 一打会儿来了
Shure: It should come back in a bit.
Choiszt: 所以这种中充电宝
Choiszt: So, this kind of power bank.
其他人：哎这个中途断了也没事是吧
Jake:中途断了再录录了再没人再看一下时间
Katrina:  我看好
Katrina: I got this.
Shure: 我巧妙的摆回来
Shure: I cleverly put it back.
Jake:救命哈哈
Jake: Help, haha.
Choiszt: 他看的时间是计时器的时间
Choiszt: He was looking at the timer.
Katrina:  你在干什么呀
Katrina: What are you doing?
Jake:计时计时
Jake: Timing, timing.
Jake:对对对然后每人都要看
Jake: Yeah, yeah, everyone needs to check.
Lucia: 一吃飞累提可谬内咔
Lucia: One eats Fei Lei Ti Ke Miu Nei Ka.
Jake:每人都要看
Jake: Everyone needs to check.
Choiszt: 现在是开始记
Choiszt: Now we start timing.
Katrina:  这是什么花
Katrina: What kind of flower is this?
Jake:啊不不不
Jake: Ah, no, no, no.
Jake:一个秒表
Jake: A stopwatch.
Jake:一个精确到后几位的秒表
Jake: A stopwatch that's precise to the last few digits.
Choiszt: 那那这么那这么知道
Choiszt: Then how do we know?
Choiszt: 是就是下午
Choiszt: It's just the afternoon.
Katrina:  放就是没电了
Katrina: It's just out of battery.
Jake:这个不中
Jake: This won't work.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Tasha:按吹昂no啥意思
Tasha: Press Chuang No, what does that mean?
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: Looks so good.
Jake:是不是今天下午命名
Jake: Are we naming it this afternoon?
Jake:上面规定具体时间不重要
Jake: The exact time given by the higher-ups isn't that important.
Choiszt: 嗷
Choiszt: Oh.
Jake:时间线比较重要
Jake: The timeline is more important.
Jake:就是不要那么具体
Jake: Just don't be too specific.
Jake:差个5分钟没关系
Jake: It's okay to be off by 5 minutes.
Tasha:按吹昂no啥意思
Tasha: What does "按吹昂no" mean?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Choiszt: 连上没
Choiszt: Is it connected?
Katrina:  但上面开了
Katrina: But the top one is on.
Choiszt: 你这是S1
Choiszt: Is this S1?
Shure: 室内设计对吧
Shure: Interior design, right?
Jake:先插电了
Jake: First, plug it in.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:插电了有电吗
Jake: Is there power after plugging it in?
Jake:没电而这上有电呢
Jake: No power, but there's power here.
Jake:互相有电
Jake: They have power together.
Nicous: 不是我超爱我擦
Nicous: No, I really love it, oh gosh.
Choiszt: 等一下我再给你一个
Choiszt: Wait, I'll give you another one.
Katrina:  上一段内个哎
Katrina: The previous one, oh.
Jake:哎呦呦没电了话
Jake: Oh no, no power.
Katrina:  在在在
Katrina: It's here, it's here.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 没有纸什么的
Lucia: No paper or anything.
Lucia: 找不到
Lucia: Can't find it.
Alice:是卫生纸
Alice: It's toilet paper.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 这这个纸是可以用的吗
Lucia: Is this paper usable?
Lucia: 算了万一我就随便写一下
Lucia: Forget it, I'll just write something down.
其他人：你要干什么
Lucia: 就稍微记录一下灵感
Lucia: Just jot down some inspiration.
Lucia: 额
Lucia: Uh.
Lucia: 或许有说明书什么的
Lucia: Maybe there's a manual or something.
Choiszt: Holly
Choiszt: Holly.
Lucia: 啊谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks.
Lucia: 这个就可以
Lucia: This one works.
Choiszt: 好
Choiszt: Okay.
Jake:10% 坐一会吧
Jake: 10% Sit for a bit.
Katrina:  换鞋
Katrina: Change shoes.
Choiszt: 昂
Choiszt: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina:  都等会儿去看内个小狗所以我要画一个这个
Katrina: Everyone will wait to see that puppy, so I need to draw this.
Katrina:  我在画
Katrina: I'm drawing it.
Jake:嘿你这个挺好
Jake: Hey, this is pretty good.
Jake:掌握了精髓
Jake: You've got the essence.
Jake:在画画我在想主要的话
Jake: While drawing, I'm thinking mainly about...
Lucia: 不我在想
Lucia: No, I'm thinking...
Lucia: 我怎样能把那个他
Lucia: How can I make this room look better?
Lucia: 这个房间设计的更好看一点
Lucia: This room design look better.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 斯嗯
Lucia: Uh-huh.
Jake:我去你这个是啥呀
Jake: What is this you're making?
Alice:花
Alice: A flower.
Jake:这什么材料呢
Jake: What material is this?
Lucia: 如果是1.5乘
Lucia: If it's 1.5 by...
Lucia: 哇好好看
Lucia: Wow, it looks so good.
Lucia: 你已经又上了一层颜色
Lucia: You added another layer of color.
Jake:确实挺牛逼
Jake: It's really impressive.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 斯这是1*2米
Lucia: This is 1 by 2 meters.
Jake:56看是不
Jake: 56, look, right?
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why though?
Katrina:  你在干什么你在画你在设计吗
Katrina: What are you doing? Are you drawing or designing?
Lucia: 没有我正在想
Lucia: No, I'm just thinking.
Lucia: 我那个做成什么样的比例比较好
Lucia: What proportions would look best?
Lucia: 我打算拿一个渔网把它挂一下
Lucia: I'm planning to hang it with a fishing net.
Katrina:  啊我也想设
Katrina: Ah, I also want to design.
Choiszt: 哎晋康这个来指导一下
Choiszt: Hey, Jin Kang, come guide us on this.
Alice:应该拿个便宜点的颜色
Alice: You should use a cheaper color.
Jake:我靠有你们好爽啊
Jake: Wow, you guys are awesome.
Jake:你知道如果没有你们我现在是什么样
Jake: You know what I'd be like without you?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:有点心疼
Alice: Feeling a bit sorry.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  那你画吗
Katrina: So, are you drawing?
Katrina:  画出来那就干瑰啊不是干枯玫瑰
Katrina: If you draw it, then it's a dried rose, not just dried roses.
Alice:对没有别的干枯玫瑰哈哈
Alice: Yeah, no other dried roses, haha.
Lucia: 干瑰
Lucia: Dry rose
Katrina:  我靠我现在应该画板
Katrina: Oh my, I should be drawing now
Alice:用点不常用的颜色哈哈哈
Alice: Use some uncommon colors, hahaha
Alice:要不然我心疼
Alice: Otherwise, I'll feel bad
Tasha: 还好不常用
Tasha: Luckily, we don't use them often
Alice:还可以吧
Alice: It's okay
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm
Jake:啊鼠标有
Jake: Ah, there's a mouse
Jake:我以为你们都不用
Jake: I thought you guys didn't use it
Katrina:  应该是玫瑰啥的
Katrina: It should be roses or something
Jake:苹果农贸
Jake: Apple farmer's market
Jake:嗯苹果应该能到
Jake: Hmm, Apple should be able to reach
Jake:我不知道苹果
Jake: I don't know Apple
Jake:他不一定有苹果
Jake: It might not have Apple
Jake:没有SD口
Jake: No SD port
Jake:因为有SD
Jake: Because there's an SD
Jake:那你要有SD也要有USB
Jake: If you have SD, you also need USB
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm
Tasha: 你脚乱蹬
Tasha: You're kicking around
Jake:那那呃
Jake: So, uh
Lucia: 哇完美融入
Lucia: Wow, perfectly integrated
Jake:共15台你三三三一人5台也行
Jake: A total of 15, you can take 5 each
Lucia: 啊真的好完美融入
Lucia: Ah, it's really perfectly integrated
Lucia: 可以看一下吗
Lucia: Can I take a look?
Lucia: 啊不算
Lucia: Ah, doesn't count
Lucia: 你已经插进去了
Lucia: You've already inserted it
Alice:无所谓拿着看吧
Alice: It's fine, just take a look
Lucia: 哈哈我害怕把它碰
Lucia: Haha, I'm afraid of touching it
Lucia: 会不会就是啊
Lucia: Will it just, uh
Alice: 不会
Alice: It won't
Lucia: 谢谢看一下
Lucia: Thanks, let me take a look
Lucia: 哇真的很完美融入
Lucia: Wow, it's really perfectly integrated
Lucia: 好看好看
Lucia: Looks great, looks great
Lucia: 乒乓客气哎
Lucia: Ping pong, no need to be polite
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina:  是的
Katrina: Yes.
Choiszt: 这个他这么了
Choiszt: What's up with him?
Jake:再来一个硬盘呗
Jake: Get another hard drive.
Jake:Wu也不是UR了吧
Jake: Wu isn't UR anymore, right?
Choiszt: 嗯
Choiszt: Yeah.
Jake:Wu能快一点吧
Jake: Can Wu speed it up?
Jake:也不一定
Jake: Maybe not.
Jake:说实话
Jake: To be honest.
Choiszt: 对啊就TC导导的导的
Choiszt: Yeah, just like TC guides it.
Jake:不不不就就就三台硬盘
Jake: No, no, no, just three hard drives.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Jake:就这样吧就这样吧
Jake: Let's leave it at that.
Choiszt: 这还能洗脱鞋了
Choiszt: You can even wash your shoes with this.
Choiszt: 这样你弄好了
Choiszt: This way, you're done.
Jake:确实确实
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Jake:多歇一会也行
Jake: Taking a longer break is fine too.
Choiszt: 马上我这个也就导完导完
Choiszt: I'll finish this soon.
Choiszt: 这样导的导的不舒服
Choiszt: It's uncomfortable doing it this way.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Nicous:  这里面都删了
Nicous: Delete everything in here.
Choiszt: 对导完就删了
Choiszt: Yeah, delete it after transferring.
Jake:导完都删了
Jake:导完你看一眼视频差不多对不对
Jake:一般我们看这个就是大小对不对
Jake: Usually, we check if the size is right.
Jake:对了就没问题
Jake: If it's correct, there are no issues.
Jake:就是分屏
Jake: It's just split-screen.
Jake:一般我你看都全是分屏
Jake: Usually, you can see it's all split-screen.
Jake:12个头对 12个屏
Jake: 12 cameras, 12 screens.
Choiszt: ok内其他的内个
Choiszt: Okay, and the other stuff...
Jake:好然后再装回去
Jake: Good, then install it back.
Lucia: 斯
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:你们有几个人一起一场
Jake: How many of you are there in one session?
Jake:那个魔力大变
Jake: That magic trick.
Jake:今天早上10个
Jake: 10 this morning.
Shure: 10个好像将近10个
Shure: About 10, almost 10.
Jake:你第几个
Jake: Which number are you?
Shure: 我第
Shure: I'm...
Jake:你是好奋友
Jake: You're a good friend.
Shure: 我第二个
Shure: I'm second.
Shure: 我第一个
Shure: I'm first.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome.
Shure: 没没没答上
Shure: No, I didn't answer it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 然后我后面的同学
Shure: Then my classmate behind me
Shure: 呃就是我女朋友
Shure: uh, it's my girlfriend.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 她电脑突然放不出来了
Shure: Her computer suddenly stopped working.
Shure: 然后又借她电脑用一下
Shure: So I borrowed her computer for a bit.
Shure: 然后所以就10点半正好答完
Shure: And then I finished just at 10:30.
Jake:所以最后他们10个人的话结束
Jake: So in the end, the ten of them finished?
Jake:没有结束
Jake: Didn't finish?
Shure: 12点多
Shure: After 12.
Shure: 9点到12点
Shure: From 9 to 12.
Choiszt: 哎等一会 这个咋么是空的
Choiszt: Hey, wait a second. Why is this empty?